begin here this morning with the outrage
at authorities over their handling of
tuesday's mass shooting inside a texas
elementary school that left 21 people
dead 19 children and two teachers
state troopers in uvalde texas now say
the police response to the shooting was
quote the wrong decision
officers waited in a hallway for more
than 45 minutes before confronting the
gunman this as children trapped inside a
classroom with the shooter repeatedly
called 911
while desperate parents outside pleaded
with officers to do more the terror
lasted about 90 minutes and only ended
when federal border patrol agents not
local police entered the classroom and
killed the gunman texas's governor is
calling for an investigation into the
police response omar via france in
uvalde this morning omar what was the
explanation given for why the officers
did not act sooner
good morning jeff the police chief of
uvalde schools was the commanding
officer here on the scene and
investigators say he's the one that told
the federal tactical unit that they
could not go in there and engage the
shooter
why he had deemed that this went from
active shooter to a barricaded person
type scenario was waiting for more
people and more equipment to show up
this as parents and also officers were
still hearing gunshots being fired from
inside the school
even with 19 officers outside the
classroom including members of a federal
border patrol tactical unit ready to
engage the shooter the decision was made
to wait
of course it was not the right decision
it was a wrong decision period there's
no no excuse for that with officers a
few feet away teachers and students made
repeated 9-1-1 calls from inside the
classroom begging for police to come and
help them she's called back and said
there was eight to nine students alive
student child called back
i was told to stay on the line and be
very quiet she told 911
that he shot the door she asked 9-1-1 to
please send the police now you had 9-1-1
calls at 12 10 12 13. 12 16. the shooter
wasn't killed until 12 50. did any of
those 9-1-1 callers survive
yes
you know i can't tell you that was with
certainty but more than one survived
days later and new details are still
coming out on what happened tuesday
morning investigators say after the
shooter crashed a car near the school he
got out and shot at a funeral home
across the street and then at the school
itself he then hopped over a fence and
entered the school building through a
door that had been propped open by a
teacher and the original story on how a
school resource officer was the first to
engage the shooter turned out to be
wrong
investigators say the school resource
officer was not even on campus
the new details have forced texas
governor greg abbott to answer questions
on why he initially praised the police
response hours after the shooting the
information that i was given
turned out in part
to be inaccurate and i'm absolutely
livid about that the changing narrative
on what happened and details on why
police waited to enter the classroom has
many rob elementary parents astounded
and angry as a mother of i
i would do that which i don't understand
is why they did it
and what that's their job
to put themselves in risk christian and
jessica garcia's daughter kylie survived
the shooting but now the family and many
in the community are questioning why
police didn't act sooner why didn't they
make the right decision why didn't they
go in
they got they got their own assault
rifles they got their vests
that's their job that's what they're
there for
just
nothing no words to describe not
disappointed
an anonymous donor has donated
thousand dollars to cover the all the
funeral expenses of the twenty one
people who were killed president biden
is expected to visit here in uvalde
tomorrow michelle
omar thank you